[Musica]
se
Buonasera a
[Applauso]
[Musica]
tutti quello che avete appena visto è un
Introduzione alla danza in volo con un
amaca uno spettacolo che affonda le sue
radici in un universo che va al di là
della mera esecuzione fisica Ma com'è
possibile questo
sono una matematica di formazione e
quando Danzo intreccio i tessuti attorno
a me in quel momento il mio corpo
diventa uno strumento per descrivere
teoremi e
teoria si può dire che la matematica non
mi abbandona mai sia nel rigore delle
dimostrazioni sia nella libertà
dell'arte del
movimento ma Comè iniziata la mia storia
con la danza in volo la mia storia ha
inizio Dopo un incidente scooter il
quale mi ha impedito di continuare a
danzare ho attraversato un periodo
particolare ma non volevo mollare e
spinta dalla voglia di continuare a
danzare in un momento di ripresa mi sono
reinventata e ho dato vita a questa
nuova forma d'arte la danza in volo con
un'amaca ho cercato di portare la danza
che prima praticavo per terra in
volo
ma ero lì divisa tra queste due grandi
passioni Da un lato la matematica
dall'altra la danza in volo Due Mondi
apparentemente molto distanti e proprio
in quel momento attraversato un periodo
di crisi perché perché la maggior parte
delle persone che avevo attorno mi
chiedevano quale delle due strade
sceglierai una carriera più
professionale o una carriera artistica
Beh io lì non sapevo dare una risposta
Perché scegliere una delle due avrebbe
significato scegliere anche solo una
parte di me e quello mi faceva
terribilmente paura e quindi ho scelto
di non scegliere i miei genitori mi
hanno sempre insegnato che volere e
potere e se vuoi una cosa ti impegni e
lotti per
ottenerla
[Musica]
io ho lottato e le ho portate avanti
entrambe ed è così che un giorno è
successa una cosa sorprendente perché
durante un allenamento ho iniziato a
notare delle similitudini tra i concetti
matematici che studiavo all'università e
i miei movimenti in volo ed è così che
ho approfondito questa idea e ho cercato
di sfruttare proprio questi concetti
matematici per analizzare e modellizzare
ciò che facevo in aria così è nato
l'argomento di della mia tesi di laurea
magistrale in Matematica la teoria delle
trecce anulari si può dire che mi sono
laureata
danzando posso richiedere per le
slide
Grazie
quindi torniamo a noi la teoria delle
trecce anulari quando noi pensiamo a una
treccia pensiamo a un acconciature di
capelli una forma di pane un cesto in
vimini o un
braccialetto Cosa hanno di
caratteristiche le trecce le trecce sono
composte da stringhe che possono
attorcigliarsi tra di loro intrecciarsi
quello che ho studiato sono le trecce
anulari le trecce anulari oltre ad avere
la capacità di attorcigliarsi tra loro
hanno anche la capacità di
attorcigliarsi attorno a un sostegno che
può essere fisso o variabile nel caso di
un sostegno fisso andiamo a esplorare la
danza del Palo di
maggio abbiamo un palo al centro e
all'estremità superiore di questo palo
sono legati dei tessuti all'estremità
inferiore invece ci sono dei ballerini
che divisi in due squadre danzano e
intrecciano i tessuti tra di loro
andando poi a creare una treccia attorno
al
palo vediamo questo questa danza nel
video se noi volessimo tracciare i
movimenti di di questi ballerini come
potremmo fare consideriamo dei ballerini
come dei punti in questo video stanno
compiendo due rotazioni e un
intreccio Ma se noi vogliamo capire qual
è il loro percorso da questo video non
riusciamo a comprenderlo Perché i
ballerini passano due volte nello stesso
punto
Ma se noi prendiamo questo cerchio lo
facciamo procedere dall'alto verso il
basso i loro movimenti ci verranno molto
più chiari e se noi invece prendiamo un
grafico piano quindi una treccia e la
facciamo procedere sempre dall'alto
verso il basso siamo in grado di
ricomporre ricreare il movimento dei
ballerini le trec culari nel grafico
dove vediamo al centro il palo e attorno
a ballerini vediamo che il ballerino in
posizione 1 si scambia col ballerino in
posizione 4 e il ballerino in posizione
2 col ballerino in posizione 3 le trecce
anulari si rappresentano tutte tramite
un grafico piano e accanto a questo
disegno vediamo proprio il grafico piano
che rappresenta Questo intreccio vediamo
che la stringa 4 si intreccia con un e
la stringa 2 si intreccia con
3 le trecce anulari si possono comporre
facendo seguire una treccia da un'altra
treccia e ogni treccia anulare può
essere ottenuta componendo un numero di
trecce
elementari questo per quanto riguarda
tutte le trecce anulari Ora andiamo a
vedere la relazione che c'è con la danza
in volo quando io Danzo intreccio il
tessuto attorno al mio corpo ogni
treccio anulare abbiamo detto che si può
graficare tramite un grafico piano
questo grafico piano corrisponde alla
figura vista in foto perché quando io do
vita a questa figura cosa faccio
consideriamo nel grafico le stringhe
rosse le mie gambe mentre le stringhe
nere il tessuto in questa figura
aggancio prima la gamba che è in
posizione due col tessuto in posizione 1
Successivamente la gamba in posizione
tre col tessuto in posizione 4 poi
intreccio i due tessuti e alla fine
riaggancio prima una gamba e poi
successivamente
l'altra in queste figure possiamo fare
lo stesso ragionamento nella prima
figura vediamo che la mia gamba in
posizione 2 è ferma e anche il tessuto è
posizione 1o è dritto mentre Chi compie
L'intreccio è la gamba destra attorno al
tessuto quindi le stringhe 3 e qu
rappresentano Questo
incrocio nel nella figura accanto
andiamo a prendere la gamba sinistra che
prima era ferma e l'abbiamo e l'andiamo
a intrecciare col tessuto che è già
intrecciato con la gamba destra e quindi
così creeremo questa
figura quindi se noi consideriamo una
coreografia sappiamo che la coreografia
è formata da varie figure e se noi
riusciamo a scrivere il grafico piano di
tutte le figure e poi lo le inconi
riusciamo a creare tutta la coreografia
che poi io riproduco in aria
quindi in questo modo tutti i miei
movimenti in volo possono essere
modelizacion
punto la teoria delle trecce
anulari Questa è stata la mia soluzione
però ora tocca a voi sì tocca a voi
perché ognuno di noi ha una combinazione
unica di talenti ed
interessi immaginate come sarebbe bello
se ognuno di noi riuscisse a trovare
delle connessioni tra mondi tra sfere di
vita apparentemente distanti Beh
sicuramente riusciremo a trovare nuove
strade nuovi spunti per creare qualcosa
forse di
magico quindi siate curiosi non ponetevi
dei limiti andate sempre oltre cercate
di vedere connessioni legami dove magari
le persone attorno a voi non li notano
Perché solo così potremo creare dei
nuovi orizzonti fallite perché è lecito
fallire però solo in questo modo
possiamo raggiungere dei
[Musica]
[Applauso]
traguardi prima di farvi danzare con me
vorrei portarvi un attimo nel mio mondo
Quindi ora vi vi chiedo di chiudere gli
occhi chiudiamolo
insieme immaginatevi sospesi in
aria
liberi immaginate il vento una leggera
brezza che vi sfiora il
viso i tessuti che Si avvolgono attorno
al vostro
corpo i tessuti che vi fanno sentire
protetti e liberi allo stesso
tempo immaginate la leggerezza del volo
e la
libertà
ora Aprite gli
occhi immaginate e sentite e soprattutto
ricordate che in tutto quello che avete
percepito c'è la matematica Ve l'ho
spiegato precedentemente e questo
secondo me è
meraviglioso ora vi auguro di volare
sempre più in alto di raggiungere i
vostri obiettivi e di inseguire sempre i
vostri sogni e ora vi faccio volare un
po' con me
[Applauso]
[Musica]
Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]
K
[Applauso]
[Musica]
Gra